vient la culture du du pas de
vague je pense que c'est un état
d'esprit qui est d'ailleurs connait pas
l'apanage de l'éducation national qui a
plusieurs
sources d'un degré de comment dire qu'on
peut condamner à des degré divers le
degré le moins fort de condamnation
qu'on peut avoir c'est quand les gens
simplement cherchent à résoudre les
problèmes sorte de principe de
subsidiarité parfois mal compris mais en
tout cas qui qui est que ce qu'on peut
régler localement on n pas de raison
d'aller euh euh d'aller reporter plus
haut et c'est pas parfois c'est pas
complètement faux c'est-à-dire que bien
sûr que sur les petits sujets les
petites questions les petits problème le
but n'est pas de de de d'encombrer le
système en quelque sorte par les par les
petits faits d'où la distinction dans
dans le système des faits de niveau 1 2
3 et et 4 donc ça c'est la moins
mauvaise des des raisons de l'existence
du pas de vague après il y a eu
longtemps le fait que sans doute
l'évaluation le système avait des
mécanismes d' évaluation qui
n'encourageit pas les bons comportements
euh c'est pas le seul domain c'est pas
le seul domaine dans lequel euh la
manière de concevoir l'évaluation des
personnels a un effet négatif sur les
comportement euh parce que en gros bah
si vous voulez avancer il vaut mieux
apparaître comme quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais rencontré de problème et toujours
à trouvver des situations lisses et
cetera donc c'est évidemment
euh une des causes je pense qu'une forme
d'infantilisation peut aussi
être une cause c'est-à-dire que notre
système
trop trop pyramidal aboutit parfois à ce
à à cela et que là on est sur une
question culturel qui mérite d'être
prise à bras le corp et qui je crois l'a
été encore une fois tout ce qu'on a pu
mettre en œuvre contre la logique du pas
de vague nous l'avons fait et du chemin
du chemin reste à faire
euh mais je crois que sur ce point comme
sur d'autres aussi il faut savoir
reconnaître les pas qui sont faits dans
la bonne direction j'ai à cœur de le
dire aujourd'hui sur d'autres sujets ce
serait
d'actualité sans se sans s'énerver si je
peux dire si on veut aller si on veut
vraiment progresser l'éducation
nationale c'est le long terme c'est les
sillons longs quand il y a des choses
qui sur 20 ans 30 ans ont dysfonctionné
on ne peut pas s'attendre à ce que en
3 ans 4 ans 5 ans tout s'améliore
parfaitement on peut faire des des
effets de discours là-dessus mais mais
la réalité c'est que on arrive dans la
durée et par des effets de continuité
c'est d'ailleurs la
madame l'avantdernière question je crois
l'avant avantdernière pardon madame la
sénatrice portter là-dessus sur la
question de de l'absence de zigzag c'est
qu'il faut de la continuité c'est vrai
en matière pédagogique c'est vrai en
matière éducative en matière de de de de
sécurité et donc euh et donc encore une
fois sur l'ensemble des choses dont je
vous parle aujourd'hui je ne prétends en
aucun cas que la situation aurait
atteint un certain degré de perfection
en revanche je prétends qu'une bonne
direction a été imprimée et que il faut
approfondir et euh et aller jusqu'au
bout de de de cela euh